it's some of the latest in military
drone technology that's transforming the
way war is fought
from stealthy surveillance high above
the battlefield
to sudden precision attacks down onto it
their use by both sides in the war in
ukraine has increased interest globally
we have seen drones been widely used in
ukraine which shows their necessity is
increasing so i think the market is
getting bigger and bigger
high-tech weapon making is supported by
south korea's advanced manufacturing
just as its precision and heavy
engineering have helped it become a
leading armed supplier now benefiting
from the war in ukraine
for south korea the war provides both
opportunity but also risk it has stopped
short of supplying weapons directly to
ukraine for fear of angering russia
which exerts influence over north korea
but the war has also increased demand
from east european nations who want to
buy ever more nato standard equipment
south korea has used its alliance with
the us and friendly ties with nato to
position itself as a supplier of choice
signing its biggest ever single arms
deal with poland for tanks
self-propelled guns and fighter jets to
replace equipment that poland sent to
ukraine
through the nato summit we exported the
k2 tank the canine howitzer and fa-50
jets to poland achieving our biggest
ever arm sale
last year south korea's military exports
set a record of more than seven billion
dollars a figure that is already
eclipsed by sales this year thanks in
part to fighting thousands of kilometers
away in eastern europe rob mcbride al
jazeera seoul